my name's Kelly Drott all I'm a
geophysicist by training I work at
Planet labs now we design build and
operate our own constellation of Earth
observing satellites so I'll tell you a
little bit about what we do and
specifically what what my team does with
the data that comes down so planet's
mission is to image the whole world
every day making change visible
accessible and actionable so that that's
our big picture mission statement so
imaging the whole world every day that's
what's really different about what we do
and I'll show you how close we are to
actually achieving that so I'll talk a
little bit about our main platform that
we're using to do this this is a
sometimes called a nano satellite a a
small satellite it's only about a foot
long 30 centimeters by 10 centimeters by
10 centimeters plus solar panels that
stick out a little farther when they're
deployed we also operate two other
constellations of satellites and I'm not
going to talk about in any detail today
the rapid eye constellation of
satellites are five rapid eye satellites
that are similar resolution and also the
sky set or Terra Bella constellation
that is a higher resolution I'll show
you I think one example from the sky set
satellites but for the most part I'm
going to concentrate on on the double
spacecraft which are the ones that that
planet Labs was founded around building
and operating and the one to the
constellation of satellites that were
coming in to its full potential right
now
so what did what do these satellites
look like in orbit this is this is a
picture of the snapshot of our
approximately 140 satellites that are
orbiting the Earth this is a little bit
dated but if you look at it current
snapshot you get something similar
so we have two different families of
orbits you can see the sort of lower
sine wave as yeah here that's an
International Space Station orbit
inclination about 52 degrees so it's
limited it can only image between those
latitudes it also varies the time of day
that it looks down our production
satellites are in this higher
inclination orbit of about 81 degrees
inclination that's a more typical Earth
observing orbit ascendance synchronous
orbit so most of the most of satellites
were operating now about 100 are in that
type of orbit so this this is also not
quite up to date but but an idea of the
images that we were collecting at the
end of last year I'll show you some more
up-to-date things just shortly here some
of the data you can see between the 52
south and 52 north and the space station
orbits were getting we were getting more
data last year now that's increased
quite a bit I'll show you how much
that's changed in the past six months or
so so here here's a graph of the up to
date of the land area that the surface
area that we're collecting images every
day for the past year and a half a
little bit more so here we have a time
on the x-axis from the end of 2015 the
the blue under the blue curve are the
3-band satellites that collected only
red green blue information since then
we've been launching pretty much
exclusively for band satellites that
have red green blue bands and also a
near infrared band it's not the devout
size of visible range so we have four
bands of information and now almost all
the data that we're collecting is for
band
data so if you look at this in millions
of square kilometers per day so we were
serving the tens of millions of
kilometers a day
the beginning of 2016
sort of around 20 million through
through most of the year then a couple
things happened in 2016 2017 that that
changed this so the end of June 2016 we
launched 12 satellites in a polar orbit
on the Indian PSLV spacecraft and and
that is this ramped up in data for the
last half of were say the third quarter
of 2016 we got up to about 50 million
square kilometers a day and then in
February of this year we had another
launch that was 88 satellites also on an
indian PSLV and that's been this
increase in data rate and now the images
we're bringing down are are more than
the surface area the land area of the
earth every day right so so we are we
are there in that sense that we're it's
about 150 million square kilometers per
day that's the area of the earth we're
above that now it doesn't mean we're
imaging everything every day there's
some overlap or also imaging some oceans
you know things like that so we don't we
don't get a picture of and I should say
clouds it's like a little bit about
clouds too but but we are getting more
than the land area of the earth download
downloaded from space every day now so
we are there in that sense so I'll talk
a little bit about this this launch that
was this year this really brought our up
to the current capacity so they said
this is in February launched on an
Indian rocket into a polar orbit and let
me see if I can play this
all right so this is a short video of
the deployment of of these hook lemme
sorry I'm going to skip ahead here we go
alright so there's a rocket launch and
then the deployment of our 88 nano
satellites here they go this is an
onboard video camera in the the launch
vehicle so you can see these are
basically just being deployed out here
tumbling in space will we then deployed
solar panels and and gained attitude
control and and so I'm after that to to
communicate with them but this is this
is them the largest deployment of
satellites in history the largest launch
104 satellites total on this single
launch vehicle was a record and 88 of
them were ours
so they keep coming you can see the the
front antennas already deployed but the
solar panels aren't yet
all right and then they play to the side
here and they keep going
sorry there's still more but you get the
idea here so alright so let me talk a
little bit about our imagery so I said
all of these satellites that were in
these last two launches are for band
satellites so they're they're imaging in
the visible spectrum in red green and
blue wavelengths bands as well as the
NIR near-infrared band so so we actually
do that in two halves of the sensor we
have to put those back together
afterwards in post-processing but it
looks like this we're imaging
overlapping rectangles in one band and
and in another band and then we we
stitch them together too to build a four
band product so this is this is what
everything looks like most of what I'm
going to be talking about today is is
only in the visible but we have the
infrared information available as well
especially a few examples of our data
things that that we've seen that are
interesting and newsworthy in recent
months so this was the end of last year
the Orville dam in California this was a
an image taken before the failure of the
spillway and after this this spillway
failed and eroded a new channel we've
we've actually since got some images of
they're reconstructing this and we're
following along as they rebuild that
spillway and Andry architect that as
well here's an example of a large
glacier collapse in tibet so this is
before and then after this is a debris
field of a large ice failure and debris
that spilled out over this plant from
the glacier that collapsed the scale and
that is about 10 15 kilometers this is
just this week so this is actually one
of the high-resolution sky set
satellites that I I mentioned but I'm
not going to talk about in any more
detail but this was in the New York
Times this week as an example of
construction in North Korea this is an
image from an airport in in North Korea
that was acquired at the end of last
year and then one
one quick example of what you can see
when you have many images sequentially
this is a series of images believe it's
33 individual images taken over a few
months period this is just off Cape
Hatteras North Carolina and showing the
formation of a new island not earlier
this year
so these are the kinds of things that we
aim to be able to see and and bring out
with our data all right so let me talk
about what my team does at Planet and
that's specifically turning all of these
images that we get into maps to to be a
coherent global view of the surface of
the earth alright so this is a picture
of the surface of the earth right so
this might be what you think of when you
when you think of what does the earth
look like from space this is what you
see on all these web maps and what we
all know of as is what the earth looks
like right but this is actually a very
artificial product this is this one
isn't ours this is from the Blue Marble
generated by NASA from modis satellite
data I'll show you examples of ours in
in a few minutes
but this is not actually what the earth
really looks like from space first of
all we don't see through the oceans you
don't see the the ocean topography but
most of all you don't see most of the
surface of the earth either so this is
what the earth actually looks like on
any given day right this is an image
from this week from the modis terra
sensor just just taken over the course
of one day so this is this is a typical
day on earth
in July alright so this is this is what
it looks like so how do we how do we
deal with that we're taking our images
all the time everywhere but but if we
had even if we image everything on the
earth on this day you can see well
you've got clear patches a few clear
patches in North America you got North
Africa a few places in South America
Australia
not much in Europe you know some parts
of Asia but not not the North so it's
it's a little bit messy so so our job is
to turn that into one single coherent
picture
all right so let me let me just talk
briefly about the whoa the tools we use
to build mosaics since this is a PI data
conference we'll talk a little bit about
the relevant PI data tools so everything
that we use in our in our workflow is
based on open source tools so we run our
whole pipeline in Python with various
parts in compiled C C++ as well the
heavy lifting of the computation is in G
del G del is the geospatial data
abstraction library if you've done any
any raster manipulation in open source
tools you probably use something based
on G del Frank Warmerdam the the
original author maintainer of juda also
works at planet labs so he's the
architect of our our pipeline as well so
we have a lot of help on that and then
in addition to those tools we use many
of the standard tools in the Python
stack numpy and Phi PI and selected
image and then wisteria which is a set
of wrappers around the GDL library that
are more pythonic for various other
things we use use many of the other
tools you're familiar with in the PI
data stack as well but these are the
main ones that are actually in the
production in our pipeline so happy to
talk about how we use some of these if
you're interested first of all let me
just talk a little bit about how we do
our our mosaicing so just in general
there's there's two main problems that
you have to do that they have to solve
in order to build a seamless cloud-free
mosaic of the world
those are scene selection and color
normalization just to regularize the
scenes to put them together so first
scene selection every every scene that
we're taking each individual take from a
satellite is roughly 20 20 kilometers
wide by
ten kilometers long and so it's a it's a
rectangle of a couple hundred square
kilometers and we're taking many
thousands of these a day so we if we're
making a mosaic from some time period we
have to select all the images that are
available in first for search all the
images are available for a particular
location then we have to rank them
according to clouds and other metrics
sharpness other sensor quality metrics
and I choose the best ones that we have
available in order to stitch them
together into one seamless picture so
here's an example we might have 25
images to choose from that overlap this
this tile that we're building in various
ways we select the two or three best
ones that are going to fit together to
give us an image in this case over
central Beijing and stitch them together
too to make them one piece all right so
that's that's one hard problem we've
we've got some cloud metrics we've got
some sharpness metrics and we might also
ranked by the the target date how close
it is to the to the center of the time
window and things like that but but once
we selected the scenes then that's
that's only part of our work even if
we've selected them well then we have to
do some normalization on those scenes
and then this is an older image that
shows some of our older satellite data
that has a smaller footprint but it
shows the variation in in colors and
different satellites but especially in
things that are taken on different days
so just due to atmospheric variations
you get huge differences in appearance
of the of the earth taken through
different conditions of haze mostly in
the early days there also some
differences in the filters that were
that are on the satellites that we're
taking images through now the production
satellites are pretty uniform so that's
much less of an issue
but but these atmospheric conditions
still still matter so you can see some
look blueish and some look pinkish and
and you know there's not the same color
curve applied to all these things we
have to turn this into some regular
appearance of what we we think the
surface of the earth should look like so
I'll talk about the one method reviews
to do that it's called histogram
matching this is a pretty common
normalization method from photography so
you have a color target and you have a
reference image in this and you have a
source image the image that you're
trying to regularize so so you want to
tune that that source image to match the
colors of the reference image you do
that by shifting the the histograms of
each color that is each band in this
case red green blue visible bands too to
match the the cumulative distribution of
occurrence in that and that that's a
good way to to normalize things in
general there are some issues with that
though and that is one of the biggest
issues is things change on the ground
and if your color target what you're
matching things to isn't exactly what
things look like now you're going to
make mistakes so here's here's an
example you've got a color target that
is brown you know so say it's it's a
fall color target and the hillsides are
brown and matching blindly to that brown
color target you get something sort of
washed out and brown but if you look at
what the image actually has there's snow
in this valley alright so so that
histogram matching is a pretty poor
match to to actually see what's on the
ground and one of the things we're
interested in is change so to make that
change visible using static color
targets will mask some of that
make it harder to see so we are we've
developed a new method that that's
better at showing at regularizing images
without changing their content as much
so this is a parametric [ __ ] that we've
made for the same image that that still
matches the brown of the hills and the
trees without leaves but brings out the
white and the valleys as you'd expect
with snow in the ground so that
parametric fit is well I'm not going to
talk about it in any detail but if
you're interested there is a talk at
Syfy in Austin next week I'll give you
the schedule for that at the end of this
talk but that's that's a more principled
way to do this this matching in a robust
way that's not going to distort the data
and just regular eyes things in ways
that we understand okay so that's that's
how we solve the normalization problem
in general we also use color targets too
we build our own color targets to decide
what what we're going to normalize to so
a nice source of color targets is the
Landsat 8 sensor so this is a global
summer color target so summer northern
hemisphere southern southern hemisphere
minimum snow and ice for the world we
also build other seasonal targets to
match different times so this is this is
one of our sources for for truth for
what the surface of the earth looks like
at a given time or in this case at a
broad range of time since the
hemispheres don't match alright and then
one other thing we have to do even with
the normalization there's still the
possibility of seam lines so here we've
got two different
well three different scenes that are
visible in individual images this image
doesn't quite match this image doesn't
quite match that image even though we've
done the color balancing and they're
roughly the same this image is a little
bit hazy but it
said you know the more or less
normalized in color but there's still
these seams visible so one more step we
do that we call gradient blending you
might think of this as feathering in
some other context but but to eliminate
those seen lines we essentially treat
this as a free bound well as a boundary
condition that we match values across
this seam and and we solve it as a
partial differential equation to smooth
that out and that's our our seamless
gradient blending so that's the last
piece of how we put everything together
now let me show you some examples so
here is our global summer base map so
this is sort of our best of all time
imagery summertime imagery and the
Northern Hemisphere and in the southern
hemisphere with a little little bit
broader and the input and the tropics to
be able to do that but but here we've
mapped something like 95% of the surface
of the earth we're missing mostly very
high latitude ice in well Antarctica and
in Greenland places that we don't
rectify the images very well there isn't
a lot of ground control to do that so we
do acquire a lot of those images but
they're not included in these mosaics
they don't add a lot to it but places
where you see the ground almost complete
coverage everywhere and and we have it
all globally match there so that's this
is a sort of static mosaic that you
might have seen for a base map in other
applications in Google Maps and things
like that that's what a lot of a lot of
people stop with the bill the best view
of the earth we're also interested in
the time dimension
since we're acquiring images on a daily
basis we want to show the dynamic
surface of the earth so we're building
mosaics not just once but
much more frequently so this is monthly
mosaics so to build up since the
beginning of 2016 and they step through
through May believe you I don't have I
don't have June added to this yet but
through May of this year there are
seventeen months of global mosaics you
can see the increase in coverage as you
go through 2016 as satellites are
deployed and then into 2017 even more so
we're starting up out at something like
60 70 % coverage at the beginning 2016
over a month and going to 95 to 98
percent coverage what we're getting this
summer you also see a change in the
early 2016 data you see different orbits
are visible there as well so there we
see that the low inclination
International Space Station orbits that
look different a little different every
months when that fills in now these
these orbits are all high inclination
sun-synchronous ones in 2017 all right
and you can see places that are that are
cloudy a lot like the Amazon like the
like Central Africa they rarely
completely fill in in a month right you
still see some gap so we're imaging
those areas all the time but we're not
actually seeing the ground even if you
you take images very frequently but but
the more image we image as we take the
more likely we are to get that one clear
day where you do see the ground there so
that that is filling in in those places
and you can see in May those patches are
are much smaller as we as we have more
and more data all right all right
so that's monthly now we're moving
towards weekly so this is only for the
continental US this is I believe 13
weeks of of weekly mosaics over the
continental United States and here you
can see some gaps those are almost
entirely due to clouds we're imaging
everything at least once a week in most
cases several times a week but there are
still some gaps in between where in that
week we never saw a clear view of the
ground but we're we're approaching now
we're averaging about 95% cloud free
coverage globally for the for the world
in a week so that's that's what we're
aiming for were and you know as the the
satellites spread out a little bit more
well we will improve that incrementally
there's a few other things we can do
operationally to help that but but we're
still limited by clouds essentially so
that that last few percent is is hard to
get
all right so let me wrap up with a few
other things I want to talk about some
of the things that were looking at at
doing next so I showed you an example of
weekly we're moving towards producing
those every week and globally and we
hope to have those as a product sometime
this year that's available to customers
another way to increase that frequency
is it's hard to do a daily purely time
windowed mosaic because of that cloud
issue that I showed you if you look at
just a snapshot of the earth on one day
it's 50% clouds so updating the the
daily mosaic every day just by finding
the good cloud free images and having a
dynamically generated image where you
have all the clear images from that day
and then you may go back the rest of the
week maybe even back farther in some
places have a dynamic mosaic that's
another another product that we are
working towards happening and then one
other thing is to use the fourth band to
use that NIR band and incorporate that
into the mosaic so all those things are
at the top of our list to work on let me
just close with a few things you can you
can do to look at and to use Planet data
the first that is publicly available as
our gallery so planet.com slash gallery
all the images here are Creative Commons
licensed by ese so so non-commercial by
us I believe so these are some examples
of planet scope images that are in the
gallery there's also our Explorer web
tool this is
available at low resolution without
login if you create an account you can
zoom in and and look at the United
States and in full resolution and you
can have access to two high-resolution
data I believe in California so that
that's another place to look at if
you're an academic we also have a
partnership program now called
ambassador's program so if you're
interested in research programs if you
have an edu account you can contact us
and and set up an account for access to
your area of interest and we can partner
on a on a project to use our data in a
research project and then finally we are
hiring so if you are interested in in a
draw at planet we have offices in
Bellevue here in San Francisco and we
are looking for people in a various in
various roles so look at our careers
page then one last announcement next
week at Syfy in Austin there are going
to be two talks by by my colleagues Amit
Kapadia and Joe kington on some more
details of what I've talked about here
the time series mosaics and the the
color balancing algorithms that we use
so those are both on Wednesday of next
week in Austin if any of you have to be
there and those will be available online
after that all right so thank you for
listening and take any questions at the
time we have I'm going to try and run
this room yeah
good exercise today I think what kind of
derived products are you offering me
doing any edge detection - you know good
vector products for industry yeah we're
working on those things there are people
doing analytics with our products that
you know so the Analects companies that
in just our data and and resell things
and and we're we're working on analytics
ourselves as well change detection is is
buy on our list we don't have any
current commercial products but if
you're interested in particular things
we'd be happy to talk to you any other
questions
over there Ohio's curious about your
cloud masking are you just throwing out
areas that have like a cloud mask like
when you're getting like a sincerest
level or are you trying to do some sort
of correction with that yeah for the
most part serious will get thrown out
but but sort of light haze will not so
yeah but for the most part if it's
really obscuring the the ground for the
mosaics purposes will will penalize them
pretty heavily and we don't end up using
them if there's anything else we can use
yeah hi if I heard you correctly said
that a mosaic is composed of scenes that
are not necessarily within the same
temporal frame so with what but what is
the range that you build those mosaics
and how do you reconcile that with a
with a task of doing change detection
yeah that's a good question so we
basically have two two different models
for building a mosaic one is the
all-time best the seasonal mosaic so
it's like that first one that I showed
you and that that could be a very wide
range of input and we're trying to use
anything that we expect the ground to
look more or less like like the right
seasonal target that we
looking for but there may be months and
multiple years in previous seasons of
data that they're used for that all of
the monthly and weekly mosaics I showed
you though are strictly time-boxed so so
everything is within that month strictly
not using anything outside of that
window there's certainly room to play
with those those two extremes and and
still fill a mosaic with the most recent
data but but use fill in the gaps with
previous things when necessary as well
but you're right for change detection
you want to know strictly when when
things are there and those those
time-lapse mosaics is the strict window
ones are the ones that have that yeah
what do your API products actually look
like
do you provide just raw image data you
provide these mosaics as well to
individual consumers or just enterprise
to commercial customers yeah we provide
access to any of these just trying to
think what we we certainly provide web
tiles at certain resolutions to general
customers or it started to general free
users in the Explorer application yeah
but for full resolution access to the
mosaics that's that's a commercial
product but in terms of the products
that are available we generally have
visual 3-band products analytic form and
products they're processed to radiance
and pop of atmosphere reflectance that
that you can download through our API as
a customer and as a academic user and as
a free user in limited areas